Bonjour à tous.
Aujourd'hui, on va parler du jeu de la vie.
Alors, non, je ne fais pas référence à un jeu de société
ou à une variante de la roulette russe,
mais à un drôle de petit programme informatique
imaginé dans les années 70
par le mathématicien John Conway.
Depuis presque 50 ans,
ce jeu fascine les mathématiciens et les informaticiens,
mais aussi les biologistes et les philosophes
parce qu'il nous montre
comment un système évoluant selon des règles simplistes
peut engendrer
des résultats incroyablement riches.
Et d'une certaine manière,
il nous aide à mieux comprendre
comment un gros tas d'atomes en interaction
peut se retrouver à former
les êtres complexes et pensants que nous sommes.
Le jeu de la vie se joue sur un tableau de cases carrées
qu'on peut prendre aussi grand qu'on veut.
Et on imagine que chacune de ces cases
peut héberger une cellule,
comme une cellule vivante.
Si la case en contient une,
on la colorie en noir,
et à l'inverse, si elle est vide,
on la laisse en blanc.
Voici par exemple une configuration possible,
très simple,
dans laquelle on a seulement six cellules vivantes.
Maintenant, l'idée du jeu de la vie,
c'est de faire évoluer une population de cellules,
au tour par tour,
selon des règles qui sont fixées à l'avance
et qui sont enfantines.
Règle n°1 : une cellule ne survivra au tour suivant
que si elle est entourée par deux ou trois voisines.
Si vous voulez, en dessous de deux voisines,
la cellule meurt d'isolement
et au dessus de trois,
elle meurt de surpopulation.
Et règle n°2 :
si une case vide est entourée
par exactement trois voisines,
elle devient vivante au tour suivant.
Une cellule nait à cet endroit-là.
Pour voir ce que ça donne,
essayons d'appliquer ces deux règles d'évolution
sur notre exemple précédent.
Ici, on a une cellule qui n'a qu'une voisine,
donc qui va mourir d'isolement.
Ici, on a une case vide
qui a exactement trois voisines,
donc il va y avoir une naissance ici
et pareil pour là
et pour les trois cases qu'on trouve en-dessous.
Au tour suivant,
on a donc une nouvelle situation qui est celle-ci.
Et ensuite, on n'a plus qu'à recommencer
pour refaire évoluer cette nouvelle situation.
On va avoir plusieurs morts par surpopulation
et aussi quelques naissances.
Et ainsi de suite,
on peut recommencer autant qu'on veut.
Vous voyez qu'appliquer les deux règles
est extrêmement simple.
Et en fait, on appelle ça le jeu de la vie,
mais c'est pas vraiment un jeu
puisqu'il y a pas de joueur.
Vous n'avez aucune décision à prendre,
à part choisir la situation de départ.
Et ensuite, il suffit d'appliquer les règles pas à pas,
sans réfléchir.
Si on revient à notre petit exemple,
on a atteint la configuration suivante.
Un carré fait de quatre cellules.
Et là, ben vous pouvez vous convaincre
que plus rien ne se passe.
Ni mort, ni naissance.
La figure n'évolue plus, elle est stable.
Évidemment,
le fait qu'on arrive sur cette structure stable
est lié au choix qu'on a fait
pour la configuration de départ.
Si on avait pris une configuration différente,
les choses se seraient passées autrement.
Pour explorer différents scénarios,
on va pas continuer de faire ça à la main.
Il se trouve que les règles sont extrêmement simples,
donc très faciles à programmer.
Et ça va permettre
de calculer beaucoup plus vite les évolutions.
Alors, il existe plein de petites applications
qu'on peut télécharger,
mais pour pouvoir en faire des belles illustrations,
j'ai recodé moi-même le jeu de la vie en python,
et pour ceux que ça intéresse,
je mettrai le lien dans la description.
Quand John Conway
a proposé les règles du jeu de la vie en 1970,
lui et quelques acolytes ont commencé
à explorer plein de configurations de départ
pour voir où ça allait mener.
Bon, évidemment,
si je pars d'une seule cellule ou même de deux,
elles meurent tout de suite d'isolement.
Prenons donc trois cellules en ligne.
Et voilà ce qui se passe
quand on les fait évoluer.
On obtient pas une configuration stable,
comme tout à l'heure,
mais une structure oscillante.
On l'appelle "le clignotant."
En partant de quatre cellules en ligne,
l'évolution s'arrête,
mais sur une nouvelle structure stable
qu'on surnomme "la ruche."
Et avec cinq cellules en ligne,
on obtient au bout de quelques tours
une nouvelle structure oscillante
constituée de quatre clignotants.
Mais en fait, on obtient pas toujours
des structures stables ou oscillantes.
Parfois, certaines structures
finissent par mourir complètement.
Comme celle-ci par exemple.
Alors, je vais pas vous faire toutes les configurations
de départ possibles et imaginables.
Ce qui est marrant pour trouver
de nouvelles structures stables ou oscillantes,
c'est de partir d'une situation de départ
un peu aléatoire,
de lancer l'évolution
et de voir où ça nous mène.
Dans les structures stables
qu'on peut trouver comme ça,
voici par exemple
celles qu'on appelle "le bateau,"
"le pain," et "la mare."
Et dans les structures oscillantes,
à part le clignotant,
voici "la balise" et le "crapeau."
Ce qui est fascinant dans le jeu de la vie c'est la manière dont des petites choses simples peuvent engendrer une grande complexité
par exemple prenez comme situation de départ la
configuration en ruche qui est stable on l'a dit mais en ajoutant juste une petite cellule dans un coin
lancé l'évolution et voici ce qui se passe
vous avez maintenant quatre ruches qui sont apparues
si je prends un escalier comme ça avec juste 6 cellules va regarder
la structure se développe on se demande jusqu'où ça va continuer
et elle finit par s'arrêter vers une structure stable constitué de quatre blocs assez éloignés les uns des autres
et il a fallu soixante trois générations pour sa
part je pourrais vous en montrer plein comme ça mais l'observation qui a fasciné conway et qui lui a montré tout le potentiel
de son petit jeu c'est l'évolution de cette simple structure cinq cellules c'est tout et pourtant regardez
et là en fait je vais devoir accélérer le film est aussi un peu des zooms et parce que ça continue encore
Encore
Et voilà
La première chose étonnante c'est qu'il a fallu
1103 générations pour que l'évolution se stabilise ce qui est quand même énorme vu qu'on est parti de cinq cellules tout bête
et l'évolution a été complètement chaotiques apparemment aucun motif récurrent et à la fin on se retrouve avec une configuration sans aucune symétrie
constitué de quatre clignotants ici et 2,15 structure stable
huit blocs de quatre 4 ruches un bateau un pain et un navire
mais ça n'est pas ça le plus fascinant au milieu de la simulation il s'est passé un truc vraiment étonnant je sais pas si vous
l'avez remarqué je vous le remet
regardez là autour de la 70e génération ce truc c'est ce qu'on appelle un planeur sommes regardés y en ad'autres ici
le planeur c'est une structure qui change de forme mais tous les quatre tours retrouve sa configuration en s'étant déplacé d'une case en diagonale
on peut en voir d'autres un peu plus tard dans la simulation et du coup c'est une structure qui avance
la présence de ce petit planner est assez révolutionnaire parce qu'elle montre deux choses
la première c'est qu'un motif peut avoir une croissance qui sera
infini dans l'espace au cours de l'évolution il ya huit planeur qui sont émis et qui vont donc continuer jusqu'à l'infini
la deuxième chose c'est que ces planeur père être de commencer à imaginer une forme de communication entre des structures
et on va voir que ça ouvre plein de portes
Depuis que le jeu de la vie a été imaginé par conway ses adeptes cherche à découvrir ou à construire des structures
intéressantes de plus en plus grande et de plus en plus riches
trouver des grandes structures stables qui ne soit pas juste des associations de structures existantes ce n'est pas si simple
la plus grosse à ce jour c'est la suivante on l'appelle tout elle est constituée de 45 cellule
du côté des oscillateurs n'a trouvé plein d'autres et notamment certains dont la période d'oscillations n'est pas deux comme le clignotant
mais peut être un nombre plus élevé
par exemple voici une structure appelée le pulsar qui oscille avec une période de 3
c'est à dire que la figure se répète tous les trois tours
Autre exemple plus compliqué prenait 10 cellules en ligne
au début on a l'impression que la structure évolue sans motif particulier
mais en fait elle se répète tous les 15 tours c'est un oscillateur de période 15 qu'on appelle le peinte à décathlon
On connaît maintenant des oscillateurs de tout un tas de période en voici un des plus gros c'est un oscillateur deux périodes
177 pour la configuration se répète donc tous les 177 tours
Du côté des planeurs on a pu aussi trouver d'autres structures capables de se déplacer
et par exemple les trois suivants qu'on appelle les vaisseaux spatiaux respectivement le petit le moyen et le gros
et aussi des très jolies structures comme celle-ci : c'est l'oie du Canada.
Ou bien des plus symétriques comme celle-là qui s'appelle 60P5H2V0. Ouais.
Or tout ça est bien gentil, on peut s'imaginer même pousser le bouchon encore plus loin
mais la structure qui a provoqué une petite révolution dans le jeu de la vie c'est celle-ci : on l'appelle le canon à planeur
Et vous voyez pourquoi hein ? C'est une structure qui oscille tout en produisant des planeurs
elle a été découverte par Bill Gosper et porte d'ailleurs son nom : le canon à planeurs de Gosper
Et cette structure résout une question que Conway s'était posée dès le départ.
Elle montre que le nombre de cellules vivantes
peut tendre vers l'infini avec le temps. Bah oui, on a des planneurs qui sont émis avec un rythme régulier et qui ne disparaissent jamais.
Et on peut évidemment jouer à essayer de construire des canons pour d'autres types de structures qui se déplacent.
Allez voici un exemple extrême : vous souvenez du vaisseau 60P5H2V0 ?
Eh bien on peut en fabriquer un canon : il est juste légèrement plus gros que le canon à planeurs.
En fait oui, il est vraiment, vraiment plus gros.
Regardez moi ce ballet harmonieux. Vous ne trouvez pas ça magnifique ?
En fait, ce qui est magnifique, c'est surtout que toute cette complexité fascinante découle de seulement deux règles totalement élémentaires.
Vous voulez encore d'autres structures ?
voici ce qu'on appelle un fumeur, c'est-à-dire une structure qui se déplace, comme un vaisseau, mais en produisant des débris qui restent derrière elle
Et en partant de ce même fumeur, mais en rajoutant dans son sillage des vaisseaux spatiaux qui vont le suivre,
on peut en faire une version dite « écologique ».
Regardez : les vaisseaux vont convertir les débris du fumeur pour en faire des planeurs.
Voici une autre structure de fumeurs assez impressionnante qu'on appelle un fumeur en ligne. Alors lui il laisse un sacré bordel derrière lui
Tout à l'heure on a vu que le canon à planeurs était une structure assez compact qui permettait de produire des cellules à l'infini
mais en fait on peut faire encore plus simple que ça. Voici une structure de seulement dix cellules au départ qui paye pas de mine
mais voyons son évolution.
Regardez : au bout d'un moment on remarque une sorte de route pavée de blocs qui se construit comme ça indéfiniment
avec seulement dix cellules au départ on peut montrer que c'est la plus petite structure possible ayant une croissance infinie.
On peut aussi s'amuser à chercher des structures en croissance infinie qui soient les plus rapides possibles
et là le record est détenu par cette structure qu'on appelle Max et vous voyez pourquoi, hein.
Quand elle évolue, et bien elle remplit l'espace d'un motif en rayures de zèbres qui est localement stable
Alors stable mais pas très robuste. Regardez ce qui se passe si j'ajoute artificiellement une petite perturbation quand on arrive au bord :
Et ben c'est l'apocalypse.
Mais la structure la plus spectaculaire pour moi c'est celle-ci : elle s'appelle Breeder One (Breeder 1).
Elle est constituée de neuf gros vaisseaux qui laissent des débris et éjectent des planeurs. Mais regardez ce qu'elle produit :
les planeurs et les débris finissent par s'assembler pour former des canons à planeurs qui se disposent en ligne dans son sillage
et donc plus le temps passe, plus le nombre de planeurs émis simultanément augmente.
C'est beau non ?
Bon, ça fait quelques minutes qu'on fait des jolis dessins, on peut quand même se demander à quoi tout ça sert.
Alors si tout ça vous laisse de marbre, souvenez-vous que ce qui fait la beauté de la chose
c'est que toute cette complexité est engendré à partir de seulement deux règles extrêmement simple sur la survie et la naissance des cellules
et c'est ça qui fait tout l'intérêt du jeu de la vie : le fait que des règles de base élémentaires
puisse donner naissance à des structures et à des comportements extrêmement complexes.
Et d'ailleurs personne n'aurait pu anticiper rien qu'en regardant les deux règles qu'elles pourraient donner naissance à tout ça.
Et c'est ce phénomène qu'on appelle l'émergence, le fait que des structures complexes puissent posséder des propriétés
macroscopiques qu'on ne retrouve pas dans leurs constituants de base. On retrouve ces situations d'émergence aussi bien en physique qu'en biologie
mais aussi en sociologie ou en économie quand on étudie le comportement des groupes. Et c'est parce qu'il nous renseigne sur ces phénomènes
d'émergence qu'on s'intéresse beaucoup à l'étude de systèmes simples facilement simulables informatiquement comme le jeu de la vie
D'ailleurs pour ceux qui s'en souviennent j'avais déjà évoqué ces questions dans une vidéo précédente qui parlait de la fourmi de Langton.
Dans le cas du jeu de la vie, on a pu pousser l'investigation
assez loin par exemple, on a pu montrer qu'il existait des structures capables de s'auto-répliquer, comme ce qui se passe avec les cellules vivantes
et d'un point de vue théorique, il a surtout été montré qu'on pouvait réaliser une machine de Turing avec le jeu de la vie.
Alors une machine de Turing, c'est une sorte d'abstraction du concept d'ordinateur.
Ça veut dire que tout ce qu'on peut calculer avec un ordinateur classique
on peut aussi le calculer avec une simulation du jeu de la vie. On peut concevoir des portes logiques, faire des opérations, des calculs
et à la fin reproduire avec le jeu de la vie n'importe quel programme qu'on aurait pu faire tourner sur un ordinateur.
Et voici l'illustration la plus folle de cette idée.
Ce que vous voyez ici, ce sont des séries de petits planeurs qui se déplacent dans une sorte de structure carrée qui les crée.
Et quand on la regarde de loin, ces planeurs qui remplissent le carré ça fait un peu comme un pixel, une case qui serait noire.
Il en existe aussi une version sans les planeurs qui du coup ressemble beaucoup à une case blanche.
Et on peut associer plusieurs structures de ce genre pour former un réseau de cases géantes blanches ou noires.
Et en mettant les bonnes interactions, ces cases géantes peuvent évoluer selon les règles du jeu de la vie.
Alors là, j'avoue que la simulation était trop compliquée, c'est pas moi qui l'ai faite.
Donc on a une configuration du jeu de la vie capable de simuler un jeu de la vie :
j'espère que la profondeur de ce résultat vous fascine autant que moi.
Alors une question qu'on peut se poser qaund on a vu tout ça c'est pourquoi utiliser ces deux règles et pas d'autres ?
Et bien Conway elle les a trouvé par tâtonnements en essayant d'avoir des règles qui soient à la fois suffisamment
simples, qui évitent l'explosion du nombre de cellules mais qui permettent de former des structures suffisamment complexes.
Il existe quelques variantes du jeu de la vie avec des règles différentes et qui produisent aussi des résultats assez riches
mais pour essayer de comprendre ce qui se passe c'est une chose qu'on peut faire
c'est d'étudier un système encore plus simple on l'appelle les automates cellulaires élémentaires
Alors petit point de vocabulaire : j'ai pas voulu vous ennuyer dès le départ avec des mots savants
mais le jeu de la vie fait partie de la classe que ce qu'on appelle les automates cellulaires
il s'agit de tous les systèmes constitué de structures élémentaires simple les cellules et qui évolue de façon discontinue dans le temps
selon des règles fixées d'avancé et déterministe et pour essayer de faire un automate cellulaire
encore plus simple que le jeu de la vie eh bien on peut essayer de descendre d'une dimension
et de ne plus considérer une grille de cellules mais simplement une ligne
si notre système est une simple ligne de cases noir une blanche
eh bien il va falloir spécifier les règles d'évolution en fonction des couleurs des cellules et de leurs voisines par exemple voici une règle d'évolution
envisageable alors il y a huit cas possibles à considérer suivant la couleur de la cellule et de ses deux voisines
par exemple cette règle nous dit que si une cellule est blanche et que ses deux voisines sont blanches et bien elle va le rester
mais que dans tous les autres cas elle devient noire au tour suivant ou elle reste noire
alors essayons de voir ce qui se passe si on simule cet exemple en partant d'une configuration de départ très simple juste une case noire
pour que tout ça soit visuel je vais représenter l'évolution dans le temps en empilant les lignes voici donc l'instant initial
ensuite le suivant, on a appliqué les règles, celui d'après et ainsi de suite
et si je représente ça de loin de façon accélérée et bien voilà ce que ça donne
Maintenant faisons une petite modification à la règle précédente. petit changement maintenant : une cellule noire isolée meurt.
et voici une image de l'évolution qu'on obtient
Et si je fais une autre modification possible eh bien j'ai une autre évolution
Pour complètement spécifier une règle d'évolution j'ai dit : il y a huit cas à
considérer est donc comme à chaque fois le résultat peut être blanc ou noir
vous pouvez vous convaincre qu'il n'y a que 2 puissance 8, c'est à dire 256 règles d'évolution possible dans cet automate cellulaire
du coup c'est assez facile de les programmer toutes et de regarder de façon exhaustive ce qui se passe pour chacune d'elles
d'autant que certaines règles en plus sont symétriques les unes des autres.
Dans les années 80 le physicien Stephen Wolfram s'est mis à étudier de façon
systématique toutes ces règles et à  leur donner une numérotation pour pouvoir les distinguer. La première règle qu'on a vu c'est ce qu'il appelle la règle
la seconde c'est la 250 et la troisième qu'on a vus c'était la numéro 50
regardons maintenant une nouvelle règle intéressante : c'est la 126. Elle est à nouveau très simple : une case blanche isolée le reste ;
une case noire entourée de deux cases noires meurt comme la surpopulation et dans tous les autres cas la case devient ou reste noire
et voici l'évolution de cette règle à partir d'une simple quasiment initial
vous reconnaissez peut-être cette figure on l'appelle le triangle de Sierpiński, ce qui est c'est un exemple bien connu de structure fractale
c'est marrant non on a des règles élémentaires
complètement locales et qui permettent de créer une structure globale comme si on en avait prévu les plans d' avance
voyons un autre exemple c'est la règle numéro 30
et voici son évolution
c'est bizarre non d'un côté on semble avoir des structures relativement régulière et de l'autre ça semble totalement aléatoire
on voit de temps en temps des structures plus grosse mais aucun motif qui se répètent vraiment
Stephen wolfram a pu montrer que cette structure était chaotique dans un sens mathématique bien défini et qu'on peut même s'en servir comme
générateur aléatoire de nombres allez un dernier exemple de règles mais celle qui a le plus fasciné wolfram il s'agit de la célèbre règle numéro
110 et elle ne diffère de la règle 126,1 celle du triangle de cirque winski que par un seul changement que le voici
si on est unis son évolution alors on s'aperçoit que d'un côté à droite la sarre est complètement blanc
par contre à gauche un espace des drôles de choses
à première vue le motif a l'air régulier partout mais quand on y regarde de plus près
on voit que des structures apparaissent se propage disparaissent et a comme des interactions entre ces structures sur un fond qui lui restent réguliers
les structures qui se propage se comporte un peu comme les planeurs du jeu de la vie
et on peut simuler aussi loin qu'on veut cet automate cellulaire ce comportement étrange demeure
c'est pas quelque chose de régulier ce n'est pas non plus quelque chose de chaotique c'est entre les deux
c'est comme si on venait de créer un petit monde dans lequel des formes de vie artificielle se développerait et
interagir est une sorte de mini jeux de la vie
en 2002 le mathématicien matthew cook a publié une démonstration du caractère
universel de la règle 110 c'est à dire qu'on peut s'en servir pour simuler une machine de turing est donc n'importe quelle fonction
calculable par un ordinateur classique
comme le jeu de la vie mais malgré cette démonstration
comme pour le jeu de la vie on peut pas dire qu'on comprenne vraiment pourquoi la règle numéro
110 fonctionne comme ça et pas les autres
l'émergence de la complexité et de l'universalité d'un système aussi simple reste une question
mystérieuse comme quoi même les programmes informatiques les plus élémentaires n'ont pas fini de nous étonner
merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo n'hésitez pas à la partager si vous l'avez apprécié oubliez pas
la clause dyk et tout ça si vous voulez creuser le sujet comme toujours j'ai écrit un billet de blog qui accompagne la vidéo qui
donne un peu plus de détails
les actualités de la chaîne c'est sur facebook et sur twitter et vous pouvez bien sûr me soutenir surtout dit merci à bientôt